hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to PT a game on the ps4 I'm
hearing a strange noise already what's
that over there
hello there's something in the darkness
no I'm just in a stuck in a room and I
can't go anywhere anyway this took a
while to get ready because it's on the
ps4 and I had actually get a ps4 because
I am not usually a console gamer I am
actually a PC gamer exclusively hello
and people have been saying that this is
one of the scariest games that they've
ever played but unfortunately for this
game it's hot on the heels of five
nights at freddy's which is one of the
scariest games i've ever played but that
being said it's on the ps4 so it's next
generation should be great graphics
hopefully it's good gameplay and
hopefully it lives up to the hype
because that's what I like the least
when it comes to the story okay then let
me harden this somewhat crying is that a
dog dying why are there cockroaches
everywhere oh it's like amnesia all over
the game
sorry I'll move on then pardon me is
that squeaking oh really oh really
that's making all that noise
alright then yeah let's definitely get
the mood right and by right I mean
horrible oh good
I guess oh good it's an endless loop I
love when I get stuck in an endless loop
of nightmares well what if he after the
game it's almost midnight
it's almost 2400 military time wait no
yeah 2400 I'm not dumb I mean jury's
still out on that one
hello someone's still indisposed no okay
that's what was that whoa okay huh um
I'm an idiot I'm pursuing the scare who
is that okay don't do that to me
so this door opened up hein all the
cockroaches to be flooding out of it
[Music]
alrighty then that's how you want to
play this game huh come on open up open
up for me who's in there
is that a baby or a dead dog I don't see
anything in there what are you doing
what are you doing besides crying for
your mama that's my job
who's in there okay so if that far doors
locked am I supposed to go back what am
I supposed to do okay never mind then
baby Oh what is that okay I thought that
was a face I think it's all supposed to
look like faces when you're walking
behind because they kind of do oh good
the orchestra decided to kick it up a
notch Oh
wondering why they were slacking so much
okay no usually that's an opportune
moment to put something something right
behind me
the arcus are really is kicking it up a
notch anything on here that I need jelly
babies chocolates that weirdo staring at
me weird over here baby
bye-bye that saw marklar talks to babies
by the way i'ma gonna be a great dad
oh okay so is this poser look closer I
was thinking I needed to yell at the
baby when in actuality let's need to
look at it okay it was gonna be fun
so that was just like what level two oh
good I thought it was gonna be a looping
level of nightmares okay
so the baby all grew up now the babies
are full-fledged oh I'm going to die all
right I still hear you don't see you it
doesn't mean that you're not there
anymore maybe still are
don't you moan in my ear Hill we did not
ask for that oh there's some crunch up
in here okay just a coat hanger some
cockroaches on the wall how's that baby
doing how's that baby doing how's that
baby baby baby okay
so I'm moving on along I'm totally fine
I'm not something wrong with you it's
perfectly normal this is exactly how the
layout of my house I want just a looping
endless series of halls so a minute to
midnight still a minute till I crap my
pants
okay see fully open now I'm I ain't
afraid of nothing I ain't afraid of
nobody oh that was a bathroom can I have
that I can has that oh I can hey this
ain't gonna be good turn around and it's
gonna be real bad oh it's just closed on
me well excuse me how is there supposed
to be a baby in here you want to explain
that 100 baby
[Music]
oh my god that is every kind of horrible
you are you're awful game you are
literally the worst what is happening
right now is that who can I see through
there oh that's a face isn't it
what are you okay huh yeah what you
can't oh it's open
yeah that's cool yeah all right okay
all right cool cool all right
I'm loving it or I'm liking it a lot
can't say so wait something changed
that's right bye-bye
Oh minutes and midnight
it's dark could think I got this
flashlight okay
Bowen yeah
by telling her it was just a game shot
once in the chest
stomach 12:46 32 or 486 3 everybody
remember that everybody write in the
comments well remember no 204 8th 6th
grade no no no 12 for 2 or 4 8 6 3 you
don't get me paranoid like that stupid
game
wait pick up just an amateur horror
games practically a professional two oh
four eight six three two oh four eight
six three I don't know what that mean
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you doing to me supposed to do
hey am i done or what am I done
what the hell happened I don't even know
what happened I'm assuming I did
something wrong I probably look behind
me and that's exactly what I shouldn't
do and if I haven't learned from all the
Slender games two years ago don't look
behind you
oh wait I still have the flashlight wait
a minute I'm still playing I still have
a flashlight
two oh four eight six three hey looking
behind me I'm running to a four eight
six three two oh four eight six three
two oh four eight six right here till
four eight six four eight
now - shut up shut up shut up shut up
you know it's kind of like SCP the stare
one the one that goes down because I'm
kind of going down to layer and going
through the same hallway that's a lot
like the theme of the game ain't looking
in there - Oh 486 three I hear a
heartbeat I wouldn't I would never dream
of it okay
hello no driving
[Music]
not happy not happy fun times what am I
supposed to do if you want from me okay
I'll move I'm moving I'm moving no no no
no no I'm sorry
did I look at something you were
supposed to be looking at me doing the
thing of looking okay what what are you
oh my god I got your eyes out that's
what I did
what the hell I didn't even know I could
okay that took forever um forgive me
Lisa there's a monster inside of me I
think there's a monster inside this
house these should be more worried about
[Music]
it's good yeah excellent
the baby's crying it's actually what I
wanted yeah okay
sorry I can hear them calling to me from
okay I'm just I'm moving on screw you
screw you a lot okay well you have to
say I'm gonna finish this damn game and
then I'm gonna go home and eat ice cream
and hug a teddy bear I'm not a creepy
one Oh what the hell was that
[Music]
why is it using the eternal question
burning and everyone's mind why is it
losing that's gonna fall on me
okay bye good to know about that
wholesome family that everyone loves and
no red light in horror games means bad
tool four eight six three oh go away oh
go away why is this hoping to go up what
was that what it's bad okay do a five
six three oh you still don't trust me oh
okay
what do i do I don't know if I'm doing
something right or wrong what is with
that hole in here like is there a reason
for that
I feel like there should be some sort of
reason for that but I can't see what's
going on that's getting louder
why Oh God there you are
are you getting a little [ __ ] no need
to be nervous it's just me I'm a normal
just like you maybe I don't know drive
you okay you're gone all right then
that was normal now I I ran into an old
friend of mine you know what the
beautiful lady that she is was that all
I was supposed to do is that the only
thing he'll what's that okay did I do it
oh look they're calling me from hell did
something online I thought I heard
something online something changed what
the hell changed something unlocked hang
on wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
he's getting interesting okay I'm gonna
try to progress again but that
definitely did calling me from Hell so
that's good I guess
okay new new stuff come on
that's new it's midnight
204 8 6 3
okay okay okay okay
okay
okay okay I'm gonna mosey on out of here
because I'm pretty sure I hear them
calling from hell and that's okay what
is that whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
someone took some drugs what that oh
okay yeah that's normal
what the hell's has happened what the
hell
oh good lordy oh boy
okay here we go turned into freakin
sanic why am i playing Sonic okay I
don't like this I don't like this much
at all but I'm gonna beat it I feel like
I might be getting close to a conclusion
here maybe I'm not entirely sure come on
I guess speed means go so I'm just gonna
go it's good here we go oh whoa whoa
whoa what is that
[Music]
Oh what okay I'm slow now that's your
call Kaiser forever but what the hell
you got fired so you drowned your
sorrows in boom baby you got fire so you
dress you yes he got a part-time job
working a grocery store
cash register only reason she could earn
a wage at all is the manager liked how
she looked at us what you remember
exactly ten months oh so I'm the guy
okay thanks for the friendly advice my
friendly fetus friend I'm gonna go now
and normal speed and I don't know what
the hell is happening where am I going
why am I going what the hell is
happening I was wandering around there
for a long time I had no idea what to do
okay no friendly advice here what the
hell is going on oh good its normal over
there that's that's a relief
that's great I'm glad this is happening
now I don't even know what I've been
playing this for so long I have no even
I've got no II I had a little bit I got
no idea what I'm even supposed to do
anymore
god I've literally been wandering around
for about an hour now but I want to beat
this I don't even know if there's a full
game I know that some people have said
that this is about Silent Hill but in
blood regards I have no idea
it's bright and vivid and I'm sure that
things are gonna be fantastically happy
and now it's midnight still good playing
this whole game in the span of like a
minute okay well then so why am I here
oh why am I here again okay are done huh
what was that what happened what
happened I don't know stop that stop
that right now
that's impolite and rude what's going on
I don't remember the number 204 863 I
think it was wait a minute one through
four yeah 204 yeah can you fix my that's
what I've been saying
[Music]
okay things got a lot weirder what
happen oh okay
development halted due to inexplicable
bog de valois huh why watch I'll do what
this is the beginning the gap in the
door is a separate reality the only me
is me are you sure the only use you
don't know that's what you said in the
beginning why okay maybe that is the my
controller vibrated didn't do that
before I don't remember what does that
sound
hello oh my oh my there are numbers
everywhere
is that who's doing that why are there
numbers everywhere okay what is that
let's move in I could do nothing for
watch then I found me walking in front
of myself pick you up in the door that's
what they asked me I still don't know
the answer to that I don't even know
what you are
you like the sorting hats brother cousin
the picking bag the batted twice bag
don't tell me I have to go through all
this crap again oh god damn it some meat
to midnight did I screw up what happened
I don't know what the hell happened
you're still there guy more advice for
me because I don't know what the hell is
happening right now I think I beat it
did I how am I supposed to know was that
who's that says something
Oh nan and mister Oh what excuse me boy
what did I do
[Music]
sorry didn't easily bid
okay I think that means this midnight
now what do we do I don't know what to
do like the vast majority this game I
don't know what to do
I sure wish I had some friendly advice
here stop that
who's there turn eyeball in that hole in
the wall oh oh I get it
I'm supposed to find things I'm supposed
to find he find things like the thing on
the stair that was actually a thing you
need to find all the things likely
either little scraps of paper or what
she has it's I don't know what they are
but I'm gonna find him I'm gonna find
him
this game's not gonna beat me I'm gonna
beat it ah it's a piece of a picture
it's a piece of this but I was who's a
piece of the ripped up picture okay cool
cool cool cool I know what I need to do
now shut up I'm busy I'm busy shut up
yes okay got another one yes I'm good
wait what
don't be glitching out on me again I
gotta beat this gotta be another one
around here I don't know how many I'm
supposed to collect but it looks like
maybe three or four pieces left I don't
know am I sure that there wasn't one
here there's a lot of things oh wait
yeah that is isn't that wait am I wrong
that is one isn't it it looks like one
hang on okay god damn it I should have
known that was gonna happen
so I'm good right I'm good how many more
pieces with just one there's just one
more piece okay it's kind of fight yet
I'm gonna find it sure
up lady I'm busy I'll get see in a
second whoa whoa hello what hello okay
okay good
my voice can you hear it the sign can
you read it I'll wait forever if you'll
just come to me what does that mean what
does that mean his hand mine never
moving us - what what did I do
why would you hide it in the options
menu hi baby how are you doing are you
doing baby hey lady I don't know if you
are the one in the message Oh lady are
you the one in the message this is
normal this is normal
[Music]
to me oh my god I wasn't even looking
[Applause]
all right you know what I've been
playing this too long I'm gonna I've
been looking up a walkthrough I'm gonna
find out how to play this so god it's
weird I don't hear a damn thing
yeah guide said that I needed to plug
this into my controller and I don't know
what this does but hey I'm gonna try
hello
maybe I need to loop through it again I
have no idea case so now I walk 10 steps
right
[Music]
making noise into the microphone
my bro bro bro bro bro do I look like an
idiot right now
I remember ah as opposed to what I
normally look like hello hello Lisa
hello he'll help me help me help me
hello hello
[Music]
damn things broken what was that what
happened why Sir go see you god damn it
oh you pretty baby won't you pretty baby
would you're pretty baby
oh you're pretty baby oh yeah but it
might be we can pay money who the creepy
man staring at me look I'm ready baby
boy are you pretty baby cuz you didn't
know the guy on the internet said I need
to talk into the place is Mike hello
hello I communicated to you from the
space tell me your secret or I will stab
you in the button I don't care if you're
a baby talk to me
Doug be a little douche hey pretty baby
are you two laughing baby are you two
laughing baby I use your laughing baby
come on give me a giggle read about the
who you baby oh yeah baby
who did he go peepee hey did you baby
who the little dead squishy little no
eyes freaky baby
who's your bird looking little weirdo
baby you are big I see your face I hear
your voice hey Lisa
how's it going Lisa Lisa it's me this is
your best friend hey come on calm down
it's okay you're gonna be just fine
oh look at you being all brave getting
out of here like a douche
baki demon my power of Christ compels
you to suck a dong go L and die oh wait
you're already dead
whatever all right you guys know what I
have been playing this game for almost
two hours now almost two hours shut up
tell you over there I got spit all over
the microphone oh you know what I give
it I've been playing this forever
I read guides online that said you
needed to talk through the microphone
deal baby to get just laughs and then
don't move and then it's a teaser for
the full game I don't know this stop
being fun a long time ago for me so I'm
gonna sign out for now if you're gonna
beat this kudos to you because I cannot
I may provide a link in the description
to what actually happens if you do beat
it but I can't do it so either way thank
you all so much for watching I really
hope you enjoyed this it was scary at
first and then it just became really
tedious but I hope the final game isn't
like that it was really good in the
beginning so either way thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more scary games that I've done or
in the description below and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
Oh